crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
yeah you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every to see you
already JUCO above ground cool goes
better than most Jane Austen
self-diagnose go down low this week last
week here we go again
[Music]
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
know the Tuesday the crappy fat-ass hmm
got right into a single this guy in and
out baby
good to see you jailer good to be here
Easter nation how are our office ideas
off Pinterest you do I got a few license
plate chains you know ran off came from
your pension nice live in your garage
sup everybody Jay Larson here Jay Larson
Tommy calm Jay Larson comedy on all
social media I got a nice announcement
October 20th I'm gonna drop my one hour
special that I shot last year I
self-funded it I'm self releasing it
self producing it I'll be doing a lot of
promotion for it I'm really excited
about it you should be excited about he
put months and months of work into it
you employed a lot of people I got a lot
of that in paints at the end a nine
again and then I got your both shows I
don't have one now and it's very good
it's really really really great so it
looks beautiful it's funny right kind of
give you some creature yeah it's
beautiful
it's it's really [ __ ] funny its
original it has a voice behind it
thank you me unlike a lot of the garbage
I see on Netflix
ya know I'm probably I'll tell you this
- I feel like releasing on my own is a
good thing because some of the stuff
that I want to talk about people like oh
yeah you can't talk about that stuff and
I'm like oh okay just let you know how
like the struggles of parenting and you
know how you work through it so I'm
really proud of it again October 20th
you know you'll be able to get the video
available for five bucks or if you want
to give a little more even more at Jay
Larson karma calm and then audible will
be doing the audio release and that'll
be available across a ton of different
platforms so keep an out for that
October 20th I'm excited and earlier in
that month October 6 and 7 they'll be in
the oil company store sickle-cell Ryan
Sickler on all social media Ryan Sickler
calm this Friday night I'm at the rec
room in Huntington Beach a brand new
comedy club down there use code ft CF
for five dollar tickets got a bunch of
other local
on my website Ryan Sickler comm but
September 29th and 30th for shows at La
Jolla Comedy Store use code crab
you'll get two-for-one tickets come out
pack the place I'm going to record the
album we'll have some fun down there for
any and all crab feast related
information the crab feast calm hit up
that Amazon link I'm not supposed to say
but I'm telling you it's a it's the best
free way to help out the podcast it
really is merch premium apps they're all
there and make sure you follow the crab
feast on Facebook and Twitter the crab
feast is supported by Casper mattress is
offering obsessively engineered mattress
at a shockingly fair price Ryan I both
have Casper mattresses I can provide
with my wife we love it too it's super
comfy durable comes shipped to your door
[ __ ] rolled up you pop the thing open
and itself inflates and it is a
fantastic mattress expands I would say
fair enough expand it
yeah it's a it's a gorgeous mattress
Casaus mattresses combined supportive
memory foam to create an award-winning
sleep surface with just the right sink
in just the right bounce now I think
it's interesting that that's what they
say because it is because Kate and I had
a memory foam mattress and this is not
the same thing at all different it's a
it's firmer and it's not as like squishy
as a memory foam free shipping and
returns to the US and Canada match the
design developed and assembled in the
United States which I always think is
great that's that's great for the
economy that's great for the environment
try sleeping on a Casper for a hundred
nights risk-free if you don't love it
they'll pick it up and refund at some
everything our offer to our listeners
get $50 towards any mattress purchase by
visiting WWF and using promo code crab
feast terms and conditions apply it's
worth it it's a supercar I lay down in
my dog that's why I gave it to Stella I
put it in her room and I was like let's
see how this thing's gonna be I get in
there read books and I'm out out and
sleep comfortably there you sleep in
there yeah that's cool man when I fall
asleep I don't head in there originally
you know I mean you go in there crab
plant I have plans ago I'm in my night
pants if I have plans to get up but
that Casper just keeps calling my name
and bringing me back through that play
um you know else who were bringing back
this week we're excited to have him back
you know you love them ladies and
gentlemen please welcome back to the
crab feast yes I am so excited to be
back you guys have made my odd new intro
on my new podcast called tinfoil hat my
friend Ryan Davis who's my co-host big
fan of you guys in here I'll put you
guys in the intro so it's like exactly
what you guys did right no big
conspiracy world homeboy yeah yeah make
sure you check out that podcast tinfoil
hats hats hats angular tinfoil hat would
Sam Tripoli all right check it out do we
go deep and you always a conspiracy
theory that you take on let's see how we
take a different one and then like we're
not going to do a second one a week
where we just talk about what's going on
this week like dude I get my news from
reddit bro we go deep in that [ __ ] man
wormholes baby yeah I love it I love it
I can't my me my girlfriend almost break
up every week because she loves watching
like mainstream news and it's so bad you
ever like take it a day
yeah you ever been like I'm not gonna
eat fast food man I'm not gonna eat fast
food
[ __ ] fast food and you go like a month
or two without fast food and then you're
driving home late night and the only
thing you see are those golden arches
you're like [ __ ] man okay I got to eat
something so you get a Big Mac that's
how you would like take three weeks off
and then mainstream news and then go
back to it it's so bad for you and I
just come home she's it's it's almost
like you member when you were young you
like had a girlfriend like she was gone
you're like I'm on watch like you know
when we had all these women marches they
were all marching for rights and their
boyfriends or a home beating off the
pornography because we all support women
are on our own way so like you know when
you're at home and you're [ __ ]
watching porn you're beating off and
your girlfriend comes in you're like
you're like stumble into like to turn
off the thing pull your pants up that's
how my girlfriend is with the light
nightly news when they come in I open
the door Mike what are you doing she's
like trying to find the remote changing
the chair
what news does she watch
she loves CNN which is the worst worst
that guy Jeff Tucker is aids of networks
he is murdering networks murdered NBC
NBC he was so bad they were ranked fifth
out of four networks how do you [ __ ]
do that through your right because it's
right right Univision or absolutely this
and then like now he's on CNN and it's
just [ __ ]
I'm just like I can't deal with it well
well we got it we got a surprise to you
before we get any deeper into this why
don't you go ahead and promote your
social media you said tinfoil hat with
Sam Tripoli if you guys go to at Sam
Tripoli TR i pol i on all like Instagram
Twitter faces on media social media
yeah that's social media yeah okay just
starting to hit all it's like saying the
United States of America but you're
going North Carolina and then there's a
reddit for my podcast called tin foil
hat show you can check that out we have
a new Instagram called tin foil hat pod
on Instagram check that out and my
youtube I put something on there daily
all right at least try my podcast funny
rent videos I called the mother of all
truth bombs just go to youtube.com slash
Sam Tripoli and if you love conspiracies
check out tinfoil hat and if you love
sports listen to the funniest sport show
out there punch-drunk sports true
alright so that's definitely something
to talk to you about can i push my date
in Philadelphia I'm at the punchline in
Philadelphia during fight week so I'm
going out there Molly's cool enough to
give me a week out there I'm super
stoked to be at Phil in Philadelphia go
to a punch Philly punch lying calm back
slash Sam Tripoli and you can get your
tickets there I promise
there will be murder dude I promise I'll
back that problem I promise you and
slash in your website outside I'm going
for blood I've been on fire
have you ever knock on for blood
carefully ah no I always go for blood
and then like I'm just these I get
called old school all the time and
comedy now because these kids just go up
and they just hope it works and if it
doesn't they just blame their dad or
some [ __ ] like that you know these
social justice warriors things I was
just thinking as a zombie apocolypse
broke out the first thing to go is
political correctness like no one's
gonna say that - yeah no one's gonna be
like where's Sarah who gives a [ __ ]
she's bitching about equal pay for equal
work
[ __ ] belladonna's blown everybody over
there keep her safe you know okay uh
last time you were on you talked about
how I want to say it was at least a
dozen cases yeah I think I was 11 I
hadn't gone to court 11 times maybe for
all traffic all traffic so 11 times and
you had beaten I don't want to be Annie
but that was like I got I got arrested
Wow I mean I got pulled over I think by
this time I'm up to 17 now so it's been
a minute since you've been back on and
you've been arrested I mean pulled over
sold over five more times yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you you all and you go to
court for everyone I fight every every
minute tooth and [ __ ] nail dog so you
showed up 17th every time in a [ __ ]
suit I do it motions dude I do [ __ ]
motions I do mostly promotion units
I [ __ ] subpoena my girlfriend I
subpoenaed her come on yeah so she had
to show up to court good I brought
documents and I set these cops up but
and I love police officers but these
[ __ ] pulled me over for nothing
and I just said what happened I have two
questions but they go back to back get
asked okay one is when you're driving
you see a cop do you start prepping to
mean like alright how am I gonna bake
them into pull me over ah no I don't
think you look do you see them I mean
you're hyper aware so are you like
looking for no I mean like when they fly
by I'm like [ __ ] and I just kind of sick
of your are guilty
no because I just I'm Armenian dude were
shady bro the [ __ ] [ __ ] bro we're
shady but over shady when I got a white
car so you know I'm Armel bro and we
they just I just see them do the
turnaround on line let's make sure the
seatbelts on
throw the phone out the window or some
[ __ ] like that and I just go you know
9:00 what's at 9:00 and 2:00 to Pam and
I do it and they pull me over and the
worst part you know arvo Joe get your
hands and not into saw you soon bye
right at night a 2-bit the worst part is
when they give you a tikki thank them I
used to have a joke about that
I got a 350 dollar ticket yeah and I was
like thank you I was like who says that
I used to do a joke about it and then it
was a funny story Dane Cook pulled me
sighs okay bro that's my joke I go dude
I've never heard you do it was a very
dark joke it was it was about how like
saying thank you up there $300 and 50
tickets like saying thank you after you
get prison raped right and it was a very
very dark joke and I dating comes up to
me he's like hey bro could talk to you
I'm like no he goes hey that's my
[ __ ] joke bro I've been doing it for
five years and I'm like I've never seen
you like trust me I've been doing I
don't know and my friend grass because
the Armenian eyes come out so he throws
me out I'm like a week later I see him
at Dublin's and he walked by and I go
hey Dan goes what I go hey could you do
that joke for me on stage I'd love to
see how years ago he goes how about this
how about I see em and my lawyers send
you some [ __ ] documents and let you
[ __ ] know you guys stop doing my bit
if you didn't see his face when he knew
he was coming with documents he was so
excited so I get my I get pulled over
right as a paper trail he subpoenaed his
girl right I did I subpoena my
girlfriend I went straight would she
have come in if you didn't subpoena her
I had to make sure I had to make sure
dude a great lawyer here leaves nothing
unfuckin okay
I got some other stories for that I
don't know if I talked last time but
it's a long story man okay anyway so I
go and I get pulled on my [ __ ]
because what happened was was that um I
was going I was going down Wilcox into
Hollywood heading towards sunset and I
go to me I was actually gonna make a
tour turn down this I forget the name
the streets Salman or some [ __ ] like
that well it's gonna make it left but
you I go to make a left and there's all
this like construction with this like
you can't enter but there were no signs
so I go to make I'm like [ __ ] and I see
a car coming this way so I'm like boom I
turn back and the only place to go cuz
la drivers are [ __ ] is this middle
lane so I go to Mill Lane and nobody
will let me in and I'm starting to freak
out because I see a cop car so I just
pull up and try to get in so I
eventually I get in I see him do and
duty literally did it like a thirty nine
point
so he pulls me over and my girlfriend's
like did you just get pulled over I'm
like yeah she was in the car oh I was
going to get high so I pull he pulls me
over and I'm like [ __ ] so I go and I
document the whole thing dude I take
pictures of everything I take pictures I
I do a video of how there's no signs
telling you that you can't turn and any
of this [ __ ] so then I get to court and
the worst thing is when they they tell
you that your noise so what did they say
they said that was for an illegal turn
when they got to it I was I traveled
down in the wrong torn leg that was in a
turn lane that I was heading the wrong
way on so then so I just what I do is I
catch him in lies I set him up that's
the same thing I did with the last time
I told you guys where I [ __ ] got the
cop to like basically I got that I told
the joke so I had him go up and I had
him go to the board I go can you explain
to me the
free-flow how the traffic was going what
is this guys is he just like are you
[ __ ] kidding or what is there like
expression on their face they are they
aren't happy they don't want to show up
right they have to [ __ ] but now because
like it you know at the time LA probably
still is broke but they were doing like
they're giving tickets everybody it was
like almost like a back tax so they and
they had to start showing up so my whole
thing is like you get the ticket you get
the day you keep pushing the date back
as far as you can keep going until at
the end they're like [ __ ] I don't
want to show up you know but he showed
up and now my god so that's your first
move is to delay delay it as long as you
can delay delay delay delay motions for
continuance motion free life continue I
dude I show up early I listen to the
people are dumb enough to hire lawyers
and these lawyers do all these motions
so I just parrot them I just I just saw
motion for continuance motion for
dismissal I'll yell it all out and nope
nope nope deny deny deny so I get him up
I have him draw where he's where it's
gonna go you know really you made him
get up on the chalk yeah I made him get
up and show us where when I was in high
school I had a guy pulled me over and he
got everything wrong everything and I
even challenged it but I didn't have doc
I didn't do it I wish I would have known
the lab me a map layout and then he had
explained or did you make him draw it on
the wall on the on the whiteboard there
is like a preset section okay preset
intersection and you just have them
display how did it go yeah so he shows
I'm like I'm like with on with on Selma
was it free-flowing
he goes yeah so yeah I go so you're
saying me it was free flowing through
[ __ ] on the intersection all the way
down to La Cienega he got or Cahuenga he
goes yes it was free-flowing the traffic
was moving I go here honor that's not
true dice heard popping up I start
showing all the pictures I'm like here
is the picture of where the it says you
can't drive down there and that's why I
was going and the law the judge got so
pissed because I sue
yeah she goes okay hold on I'm gonna
decide on this a little later
go sit down so she has me go sit down
and she goes through every case I
actually cross-examined my girlfriend
forgot to talk about that my
I'm like Dana how was it flowing did you
see I was going well which way was the
traffic could I turn here now and then
and they only oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
dude
and then I can't a show like the Triple
E and they always basically yell uncle
these judges okay okay stop it stop it
enough enough
and then he's not gonna give yeah yeah
and so then they swing into that [ __ ]
11:30 lunch for two and a half hours so
then it got creepy because the judge
dismisses the the cop but the cop stays
the whole time oh yeah we're talking two
more hours she made me sit there waiting
for the go through all of her cases
and then she goes okay come up here you
know I really want to find you guilty of
this cuz your attitude is pretty shitty
I said that yeah she goes your attitude
is pretty bad you're up here very
aggressive I'm like I'm armed I
literally go I'm Armenian this is how we
are we goes ero this is a [ __ ]
fireman Jews I don't care you were very
disrespectful but in the I the law you
know I mean for in the eye of Justice
I'm gonna drop your case because you
couldn't go there was nowhere for you to
go
case dismissed I'm just like sometimes
they're the place my girlfriend then we
look back at the cop was just staring at
all bet he looked like Michael Clarke
Duncan from the Green Mile just [ __ ]
me mugging me oh man wait did the people
really in the room go nuts when I when I
beat up the first I'm 100% [ __ ] crazy
it's like you and just but listen while
you're waiting there how many people do
you see get up and do what you do they
tried they're just not they just have
never seen anybody I've never seen
anybody in traffic court ever contest it
like that they just stand there and the
judge just goes alright this that and
the other go thank you and they bounce
and well mostly their argument is like
hey he's just doing this because I'm
Mexican that's all they say if I was why
I wouldn't be getting this is like okay
next next I'm the one who actually I
come
game playing dog I'm like I'm like the
San Francisco 49ers in 1985 with the
West Coast offense I have all my moves
predetermined I set him up
I'll all him into a little sleepiness
net my drop hammer on them and I'm
high-fiving Armenians out the [ __ ]
room you know my girlfriend that's
fantastic so you have to file a motion
and do that how do you yeah they tell
you how to do you go the first time you
have to do some subpoena they tell you
how to do it you subpoena people and you
just walk up again yeah be a court and
show up I actually tried to get a case
dismissed because my witness didn't show
up they're like no you had an ample time
so I had to cross your witness well you
know if you remember the story told the
reason I got tickets cuz we are in
standstill traffic I was leaning over
trying to make out with the chick that
was driving and this cock-blocking
officer comes up walking up with his
[ __ ] he literally that's how slow
traffic was he pulled me over with a
flashlight
he's like dude I'm trying to make out my
girl whatever bro pull over and and so I
told the judge that and she quoted
Shakespeare about love this is the guy
that's truth and then she she dismissed
the case and when she goes
case dismissed there's a chance we
believe the little guy it was so great
that's awesome so I used to have a bad
drug problem and uh which was your
favorite what do you mean your favorite
drug Oh blow was just great it was that
was okay it was just great it was great
but I I don't know if I should tell this
story but I once got robbed by a hooker
twice in one day trying to buy drugs
from the same a same hooker twice in one
day because like it's like I would
always get sober and twice in one day
and because like I would get sober and I
get rid of all the drug dealers names in
my phone so I'm not gonna do it and then
you get that moment where you're like I
haven't got anything to do for three
days so let's get a little weird and you
oh [ __ ] I don't have anybody number so
who's got drugs hooker so I'm driving
around and I see this hooker I'm like
[ __ ] man this girl's hooking at [ __ ]
noon she's got problems you know I'm
saying so I'm buying that she knows
where drugs are also saying probably
cocaine yeah I'm like hey man she pulls
in drink cop no I'm not cops I'm like
I'm looking for some you know yeah yo
she's like oh honey I can take care I
know where to go and I've learned that
if they grab their purse they're not
coming back that's like the anchor you
gotta be like leave the purse yeah so I
know you come back and she grabbed her
purse so I set out that my [ __ ] 45
minutes later and I'm driving around
like god dammit
I've learned my lesson so I'm driving
around get our laters here again I'm
like there's no way she'll do it to me -
there's no way she'll do this to me
[ __ ] twice right so I go I pull up
she's like ah baby I watched over the
first time I gave her like 60 which was
nothing yes not so so anyways I go and
uh she it's very funny
she she goes baby I'm sorry we'll do it
right this time so I go okay you sure
she goes yeah I go here sixty bucks
she goes okay I'll be right back grabs
her purse I'm like it happened again so
I'm like I'm like in this mode I'm like
[ __ ] this I'm gonna do it so I Drive I
see another hooker I'm like listen I'm
on [ __ ] I need to get the stretch
like cool I'll go take care of you so we
pull over she goes and grabs her she
jumps out the car I start to drive I get
pulled over they're like what's going on
like ah just nothing me and my French
like what's your name I'm like [ __ ] I
don't know so they're like and so the
girl gave him me the [ __ ] Yayo and it
was like nothing dude so the cop is like
where is it I'm like I don't know what
you're talking about
she's like where is it and he's like he
starts going through my wall he pulls it
out and he goes is this it I'm like [ __ ]
yeah that's it which is but number one
rule you not really you don't say omit
anything your lawyer didn't tell you
that so she goes
later but he goes where's the rest of it
I go that's it he goes how much you pay
for this
I go 60 he starts laughing the hooker
starts laughing so I had done I I done I
you know I have won the longest running
show side the second longest-running
show ever at The Comedy Store we hold on
did you get arrested or he got arrested
you did I stayed the night you stayed
the night which is the only night dude
you just got go jail one night you're
like I'll ever need to go back ever so
were you drunk tank for that yeah dude
the minute they know it's your first
time if they know it's your first time
they throw a homeless guy was about to
show his pants Olivia that's the rule
everybody talked to like how I was your
first time this dude just [ __ ] his pants
every there's like a guy on call who's
gonna [ __ ] his pants for you so he comes
in there shits his pants
so anyways well did you go to court and
defend yourself on that I did but I
called because I was nervous because I
could I can't leave the country if this
thing gets [ __ ] I get I know I could
get a [ __ ] million traffic tickets
and still be able to go to Canada if you
get a DUI or drug busts you're never
gonna be able to go to Canada ever I
don't know really
oh yeah for how long it's for I mean
like dude DUI you can't get into Canada
nope
really nope Josh Adam Meyers gonna stay
put like walking like Joey Diaz like he
has a huge following there you can't go
there because of a DUI nobody is like
but yeah DUI like what's-his-face tried
to go there arm who's a really
good-looking British comic with the long
curly hair and the Russell Brand yeah he
tried going there they turned him
[ __ ] back no I don't know yeah so was
he driving so I go and it's like I've
been doing this charity event for like
it's going on our 16th year it's called
the Armenian bone marrow registry and
that's great yeah
and it's like one of the weirdest thing
because it's one of the few podcast it's
one of the few charity events where you
actually see like the results of your
like you know you're volunteering sure
like usually like hey come down
supporting we're gonna fight it and you
never hear anything again
well they've built like since we started
doing this and not that we're the only
event they do they do a lot of events
but they've built like giant hospitals
in Armenia
my name's up on the wall that was
Armenian man the year one time I see
twice twice actually yeah twice every
man by who by the board picked me as
Armenian man the year what board the
Armenian bone marrow registry that's
located LenDale my [ __ ] home of my
Glendale Thank You Linda that I have 13
and 4 up on the wall problem so I go I'm
[ __ ] I'm broke at this time to I'm
like I'm not I don't have any money I'm
[ __ ] barely getting by dude and I'm
like [ __ ] I can't afford a lawyer so I
go I have to pull in a favor so I call
the head of the board is Mark Geragos
the [ __ ] dude who represents
everybody and you know you always see
him on television he's like the legal
guy ok he's like the number one like
dude if you've done some shady [ __ ] this
is who you go to he got on the phone he
goes triple e what's going on it's like
I got two problems he's like what you do
I'm like God drugs he's like Oh Triple E
what are you doing he goes I'm gonna
help you out you doesn't allow work for
the board I'm gonna take care of you
you Christ you man your man the year has
gone Balu so he comes and he [ __ ]
sends his lawyer and they defend me and
they keep pushing it back pushing back
push back turns out this cop that
arrested me is shady as [ __ ] he's like a
super shady cop and the police union
shows up going we're not gonna push this
any farther we want the the charges
dropped
we don't want it because my my lawyers
were going to do an inquiry into the
officer and they would have found out
he's a shady [ __ ]
and the case got dismissed damn so
[ __ ] lucky didn't charge me a dollar
I got funny believable karma when it
comes to that play hey dude I love doing
the event it's just like I don't ask for
nothing except a little legal advice
once in a while I mean I drove you I
drove with you to Vegas a couple crises
ago and no incidents no problem no
problems you're the you're the first
person to say that about my driving
napple hate my drive I didn't drive back
with you because I remember I had to be
back super early and I flew back but did
you get any tickets on the way back I
love that drive that's a great drive I
love going to Vegas I've often thought
about moving there I just that's home
though right well that's college when I
went to college you know we started me
and Doug Stanhope started out there Wow
yeah Vegas is now it's like got eight
comedy clubs it's [ __ ] jumping you
had a story you were saying something
about the green room in Vegas well so I
was doing then I'd used to do the
naughty show all the time and we get
hired to go do some stuff and we were
supposed to work with these guys this
one Club but the casino got like no we
don't want you porn stars here which is
totally weird you know the funny thing
about the Nandi show isn't so ahead of
its time now it's like kind of bland now
because it separately I walk in one
night okay I'm uh I was at the store and
then I went to the Viper Room to see to
see your show now I it's naughty
shoulders just my other show that's the
greatest show ever I put on what's it
called called The Rock and pol world
championships okay well it's the
greatest show ever I think it was that
because I walk in and [ __ ] too-short
sitting right here I can pull look at so
much weed I was like [ __ ] trippy man
and it was to eat that the room was
tears they were the hottest I've ever
seen a woman ever in my life was Ryan
Keeley that night she was a penthouse
pet and she was I've never seen any more
more attractive man it was the greatest
show I've ever put on it was the great
rage what was it it was a pole dancing
competition it's a karaoke pole dancing
competition like remember the old whites
thank video here like he's singing is
she just cried to Ghana you go you know
like that's right so they work together
and it's just and I'm the hype man how
many times you done it I did I'm about
to do it again I want to do it in Vegas
with a couple couple come companies want
a live stream it so I'm working on
setting that up
I love producing my own [ __ ] yeah so I
go to the so I'm supposed to do it
during the AVN's I always get hired by
different companies to do different
stuff like fleshlight always hires me to
do man on the street stuff and I [ __ ]
love it
I love it and so I'm supposed to do a
naughty show out there but the casino
gets cold feet and they don't want to do
it so I have to show somewhere so
somebody hooks me up with the guy who
runs the green door which is this
notorious swingers club in Vegas
I call them up the guys will [ __ ] do
it man well [ __ ] - I'm gonna get you
a hotel room dude we show up this hotel
room dude it is one entire floor of the
Paris I mean I'm not lying to you [ __ ]
and I tell you it's the entire [ __ ]
floor I bring [ __ ] Jason Tebow within
two seconds in a bathrobe walking around
like he's [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
Rothschild and [ __ ] I mean dude I got a
guy in a bunny suit walking around it's
just like it's amazing so we go and do
this show sells out in we sell 400
tickets in about two minutes HS sells
the [ __ ] out so we go there and we're
doing stand-up and it is chaos man it is
the craziest show we've ever done and I
don't know if you've ever done shows in
like swingers clubs before probably not
no no but swingers clubs in America
aren't that they're really creepy as
[ __ ] it's like almost like a warning
like hey unattractive people are about
to be [ __ ] and you might not want to
right and it's always black eyes and
dreads banging just polar bears just
cease yeah I had my dick and do
through-hole solar wooly mammoths women
lighting it up dude and they're just
lighting the [ __ ] and I'm like doing
comedy why dudes are [ __ ] polar bears
in the corner
neither
well you don't stand because it's a
naughty show and we're doing stand-up
there that's crazy
and we just have this guy called ah
dirty diamond would come up he'd take
all the Neil Diamond songs and make them
filthy like he do like gay 3 sometime
ba-bump and it was like it would just
crush it would just crush and we had the
best [ __ ] time so I'm it's there that
well that shit's going out the crowd and
you got stay in the pocket dude I do a
play-by-play I'll do play bye I've done
so much play-by-play in my life
mm-hmm why I've been like having
horrible situations like I got jumped at
at one club by this guy and the whole
time he's punched me in the face I'm
just doing play-by-play and talking [ __ ]
away in the mic yeah I wouldn't drop the
mic I just like you're a [ __ ] little
[ __ ] punch me in the leg why dude you
don't give up the mic no I never give up
the mic man no laid out where were you
I think I told this story before so I
was just basically this girl was like
trying to get like she wants she was
like heckling everybody was actually do
you guys remember Angelo Bowers yeah of
course yeah it was his first road gig
and this gorgeous chick was heckling him
so I like dirty shell I sit in the back
and I watch the crowd I'm like who's
trouble I'm like who's I'm like Patrick
Swayze Roadhouse right I'm looking for
left boot right left boot homeboy watch
for that and you see who people yelling
it's why I just started loading for a
bear you know like just putting [ __ ]
bullets in the [ __ ] bear gun and this
girl's heckling him so I start [ __ ]
so I could on and say she starts
heckling me and I told her I think I
told a story didn't I tell the story
about the girl who sat on my face for
maybe I don't remember is this the
dirtiest podcast you've done no no
that's actually no okay perfect so I'm
doing how she starts heckling me I start
hitting her but I started like rocking
her because she's like this lipstick
lesbians
which are just like chicks who are mad
at dick so they go hang out with
lesbians for a little while until they
realized they don't like [ __ ]
softball or paying for their own [ __ ] or
fixing their own flats right all right
then they run back to dick while she was
in her I hate dick mode and I start
racking her and then she started acting
like she was gonna move me right she's
like oh my god don't let your ass write
a check you can't cash because you don't
think I'll do it I go I know you won't
do it she was laid down I go what she
goes I'm gonna sit on your face right so
I lay down this is a true story she gets
buck naked she sits on my face on stage
and but dude she is I mean a [ __ ]
I'll like on a scale of one to ten she's
at la twelve Wow that's how hot she is
so anyways I like an idiot I tell people
not to film it if they would have filmed
that I would have been I would be
selling out Staples Center go back in
time like if I had a time machine I go
back I go let them film it so she gets I
get up I go I did not expect it to
happen the place is going like triple e
boom all right they go [ __ ] nuts I
didn't know where this tiny lesbian
[ __ ] just this tiny little lesbian
jumps onstage just starts beating the
[ __ ] out of me right just starts white
like an angry Chihuahua right just
attacking me I'm sorry shrug her off I
know where her gay friend jumps onstage
and it's like shut up [ __ ] grabs me by
the head starts punching me in the face
I can't stop laughing because I'm just
[ __ ] riding him with the mic in my
mouth you know I get this a lot I get a
lot of people wanting to come up and
fight me all the [ __ ] time on stage I
did Santa Barbara with you years ago and
somebody threw this somebody threw their
[ __ ] shoe at you yeah and they were
all furious and they just Chuck the show
what Barbara we did so true it is this
oh the velvet velvet Jones no it wasn't
that one it was when we did the actual
college one oh yeah yeah Terry Oh way
back yeah that was before
what was that well years ago you crushed
and I went up there and I just was like
drawing page John you are that's right
you were drawing pictures and [ __ ] and
finally somebody just threw a shoe at
you dude I was done well wait is that
the the man the the old dude I can get
into that one I won't tell this other
show though I want to hear I'll get into
the man dude one so I get hired to do
fat Mike's birthday party has anyone
ever heard of Fat Mike from no effects
you ever heard the band no effects
they're like a famous black punk rock
band this guy made this like the Warped
Tour he was like he was like so to have
his time and he was really amazing
because in a weird way he was like dice
and that he blew up with no radio play
he never got played on the radio
intimate and his wife is a good friend
of mine who I think the world of names
so much snake oil and she's a famous
BDSM my model she does like BDSM
mistress stuff and she actually came on
the show one time and a buddy of mine
named Brian Jarvis was played The [ __ ]
and we did something like it was Johnny
Carson you know Johnny would always have
those animal Wrangler oh this is a
little monkey like he likes to dance so
he so I acted like I was Johnny Carson
and her animal was his get the [ __ ] and
she would do all this crazy stuff so we
always play we always kept in touch and
she goes I had fat Mike on my the
naughty show way back in the day and it
was like kind of funny because the rules
was like in Fat Mike whence come on but
he needs a bottle of Jack an Eightball
coke and I was like okay I can make this
happen because he's a famous rock star
so he comes on I give him the drugs he
[ __ ] parties we all hang out and they
you know they've always stayed in touch
with me so she calls me and she goes Fat
Mike wants you to host his his birthday
party he's turning 50 I'm like oh [ __ ]
man okay how long is this this I would
say this is about six months ago I was
very guy David I want to say David Ross
and Keith Carey
we're also booked I was asked to host
and I was like okay I'll [ __ ] host
this yeah I'm give a [ __ ] so I show up
it's at this BDSM dungeon next to LAX
dude do you know that that's all we're
all the weird [ __ ] goes down always
there because like these dudes business
guys everything I want to fly and get
pegged in the ass and fly back out you
know so they always true all the creepy
people are by the by the airport so this
this dungeon and every night's a
different thing like one night it's like
BTS and the next night is like people
like cross dressers it's like it's just
a place where people go get weird you
know and god bless them so I show up and
I'm like okay it's at this weird [ __ ]
bar I walk in and dude everybody's
either leather daddies or cross dressers
it's like this like everybody's dressed
up either a bondage stuff or they're
like cross-dressing or something cuz
like Fat Mike is like in some weird ass
[ __ ] him and so my where and he's
celebrating his 50th birthday which in
punk ears is like 98 years no he makes
it the [ __ ] 50 in the punk world
right here so I've just hanging out and
I brought my friend Vicky cuz she was a
huge like Fat Mike fan and no effects
fan so she shows up she's like oh my god
at least punk rock royalties here
they're all hanging out I'm like okay
cool and so I'm walking around and I get
did they do
weird [ __ ] shells dude they did weird
[ __ ] shells man who they're like
leading up to the show like they did all
these like bondage weird things and
people in the bondage club in the bottom
but dude it was like holy [ __ ] man
you're like like you think I'm crazy
with the stories I just told I this girl
literally called me vanilla she's like
you're [ __ ] vanilla I'm like what are
you into she's like I like to have sex
with a knife to my throat I'm like
you're [ __ ] you're in the felonies
that joy your turn yeonbok fries so just
one woman went up this this black none
and this black none and this [ __ ]
this white priest went up and they
[ __ ] like they [ __ ] branded her
and
cut off a piece of her [ __ ] [ __ ]
ate it like it's crazy ash it was super
hot chick walked on [ __ ] glass
dancing like a little elf I'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on here man it's like
crazy-ass [ __ ] so that's beyond I mean
that's not what I would think bondages I
didn't know Bonzo there's limits they'd
like well I mean some people are into
that [ __ ] yeah apparently yeah not me
though not my thing and so you know just
weird like [ __ ] people getting cross
nipples and set on fire and [ __ ] like
that just weird that sounds so now for
some comedy I'm following the [ __ ]
cannibalism time for some comedy
so I go up man and I just realized very
quickly I am Vennela I'm the most
vanilla dude in the pond and I'm a
weirdo I'm in the weird-ass [ __ ] and I
am vanilla for this room nothing is
hitting with this crowd I am bobbing in
front of all my rock heroes I mean dogs
dick but what happens is I start getting
heckled by this cross-dressing Minotaur
looking [ __ ] I'd seen him
walking around he had this big puffy
hair big [ __ ] beard he had a jew-fro
beard he had those devil horns implants
and he had all black eyes he had the
like he got contacts in his eyes so they
were all black al beard
wedding dress I'm getting bombed and
every I'm bombing I'm bombing I'm
starting to sweat I'm bombing I'm like
my friends must hate me right now every
time one of my jokes didn't hit he would
yell I want to [ __ ] you in your ass the
place would explode it laughter and then
I would return fire again so I stopped
doing my act and mean this guy said go I
literally thought I was in Narnia and I
was getting heckled by The Lion the
Witch and the Wardrobe at one [ __ ]
time and
like how do we did [ __ ] great bro
he's [ __ ] sick try having a normal
conversation looking like that just
[ __ ] crazy everybody look like they
were man I just get weird gigs dude
simply wait did you bounce back what did
you bounce back that was rock dude I
just start doing crowd were driving
everybody up and did it had the other
comics do well they were all just like
freaks - so they just started talking
about all the I brought I like dude I
take the [ __ ] bullet yeah I had to
get people from [ __ ] fisting to
[ __ ] hahaha comedy that's that that's
that's a Patrick Swayze [ __ ] dude I had
the [ __ ] regulate you know most
people won't stand up there long enough
to [ __ ] turn the plane into a
building I don't give a [ __ ] we're all
gonna leave him
I want to here we were talking about
this fight you just had on stage but
y'all we were talking earlier you said
there was an old dude that wanted to try
to fight you on stage is that so no this
is a different night so I get hired and
I've never been asked back to the
whatsit the venture harbour comedy club
[Music]
I've never been but I've always wanted
to go I love doing it he's a nice it's
beautiful beautiful area there it is a
nice little beautiful I do there now you
know I usually pack it out when they
help me advertise you know some of these
clubs just think you're gonna show up
you do all the work and everything we'll
take all the money I did this one clubs
not gonna say the guy I was doing a tour
and I booked a one-nighter there on a
Wednesday I think and they're not open
normally on Wednesday so it was like a
bonus night for them and I show
we sell 50 tickets 50 tickets in like
the mill no I'm like that's fine because
I had a cap of like 400 bucks I could
make that night and I have to pay out
everybody off of that so they're like
hey man I wait you know we wish there
were more people there I'm like them
[ __ ] advertise I can make $400 you
could sell the place out give away
tickets make drink [ __ ] money
some of these places on its the clubs
that like really aggressively promote
people like [ __ ] house of comedy
Tammy and uh you know those guys Rick
they run a [ __ ] great Club and like
this Philly club that I'm doing like
they're already pushing it really hard
but so I do the venture Oh a comedy club
and when they promote it we pack it out
I did not he shows there was a lot of
[ __ ] fun so I get I get I get asked
to headline a week in there and I'm like
[ __ ] yeah this is great so like bring
whatever you want so I bring Eleanor
with me mm-hmm
Eleanor is a [ __ ] murderer so I bring
this guy David dearie didn't sat on if
you guys need somebody tells amazing
stories get David Deary on your shell he
has the best acid trip story you'll ever
you young and believe this but your
times over right now believe good
traffic ticket to go fight so David's
one my favorite comics she's a good
friend of mine and then Eleanor just
like you know you see this big push for
all these [ __ ] she's female comics
and you look at like Christina
Pierzynski and you're looking at Eleanor
you're like they should be have 19 shows
you know on a million [ __ ] different
things cuz they're so [ __ ] funny
you know either pushing these [ __ ]
unfunny but push these people so I'm
like I want you to I want them to see
you come feature for me so she comes out
David dear he goes up and just [ __ ]
lights the room up I'm like oh and he's
filthy I'm like oh this is perfect then
Eleanor goes up lights the room fire
dude I'm like okay this okay now that's
that's really hot in this room oh [ __ ]
so I'm like okay I think I can do well I
think this is my crowd so I go up and
Ralph gay is wrong hole man there's just
something
something is not [ __ ] working and I
am not doing well so at some point it's
been the jokes I start doing crowd words
I do I just started lighting people up
it starts going well well as I'm
watching this [ __ ] I'm watching this
as I'm watching Ellenor there's this one
drunk couple they're about 70 years old
shit-faced 70 just heckling everybody
just hackling everybody root you know
and they're [ __ ] lying about I go if
this [ __ ] lights me up she starts
saying [ __ ] I don't even know so I'm do
my set it's going weird this she's
heckling me I'm giving her [ __ ] places
kind of laughing giving her [ __ ] place
so I'm like 20 minutes in this I'm still
getting heckled nobody at the club's
done anything so I go sir you look like
a guy who likes to have his wife have a
[ __ ] five guys run a train on her he
goes I go yeah that's what you like
no they just nobody film it they did it
I'm just saying nobody [ __ ] called it
running a train on baby they did baby
what they call the oldest moves yeah I
think he's joking so he walks up to the
stage he's like I'm gonna [ __ ] beat
your ass so he's walked me 70 he's 70 75
like is he facing he's like trying to
find the answers and I think this is a
giant cage Tiger bag yeah he's like I'm
gonna kick your ass if I can find the
entrance of there I literally walk this
dude to the entrance because I think
this is [ __ ] hilarious I go dude he
walks up he goes I'm all he gets on the
stage he's like I'm gonna beat your ass
and I start laughing and I look to crowd
and the entire crowd has their phones
out like this and you nobody stopping it
[Laughter]
I'm gonna [ __ ] it man I'm about to beat
the food I love value you don't think
the wrong end is striking is
you think it's get beat I don't want to
be on the internet getting my ass beat
by an old dude so I'm like ah [ __ ] all
right dog okay man I want this I don't
need this but you're gonna [ __ ] get
it
and up comes Allen or grabs this dude
and bounces this guy really
Ellenor [ __ ] women wrestling Wow was
sleeping in the greenroom here's a are
you sleeping and he [ __ ] he didn't
even bother she bounced him no one could
argue with a woman grabbing a man and
dragon dude I've been doing this joke we
need more female bouncers and clubs
especially in commie clubs cuz he's like
you see that girl in Philadelphia who
I'm [ __ ] not oh yeah she's like
yelling at people young I lick my
[ __ ] right cops showing up she's like
my god huh well I don't believe in white
privilege but if exist that is it he
pops a lick your [ __ ]
right so so I was actually doing a show
it's very funny I was doing a show at
The Comedy Store one time and I Brody
Stevens and I love Brody Stevens all my
heart but sometimes he likes to end his
act and then do your intro and take five
minutes of your [ __ ] time introducing
you and you're like come on okay go so
this girl is heckling him just like
heckling him and she's Fiona and Ice in
the back and I'm watching he's like it's
triple here we go you're gonna love this
one
cuz that's thick like whenever it's a
rough room and I walk in there like oh
it's a Tripoli shell I'm like what the
[ __ ] does that mean
like I just I just love [ __ ] shells so
they're like yeah it's a Tripoli show so
uh he's like Tripoli gonna love this
chick I'm like I just wanted to my jokes
y'all you gotta [ __ ] love it so I
finish this is acting like introduces me
and we just had this weird interaction
where he won't go he's like trying to
like either he didn't think he was doing
well or he just he he just kept talking
during my act I'm like okay Brody it's
[ __ ] cool okay my time move on and I
don't know where she comes up and she
starts screaming at me she's this
Australian she she's like [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I mean screaming you have a great
Australian accent so she's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] you and I'm like what the [ __ ]
going on so I start like ripping into
her and the place going crazy so this
goes on for five five five minutes the
bouncers aren't doing anything cuz
they're all [ __ ] like hipsters and
skinny jeans who all look like they play
keyboard and Death Cab for Cutie no
there's no testosterone [ __ ] there so
she scream at me I didn't know where
dude this chick walks up grabs her by
the Fate grabs her by shoulder it looks
certain face goes okay enough of you
turns around smacks her on the ass picks
her up throws her over [ __ ] shoulders
what and walks her out of the club who
Elinor did that No oh this is so walks
around the club sets it down cuz I can't
go who are you she goes out no I'm in
the show this [ __ ] is annoying I go
you're literally a superhero you just
saved the [ __ ] day so anyways we're
watching the drunk chick through the
window at the Comedy Store five black
guys pull up in a car grab her throw in
the car and take the [ __ ] off and I
don't know what happened I'm pretty sure
it's on pornhub
it's probably on porno Dan yeah did your
magnet
I love chaos you're a magazine
I love chaos what's the used to work at
a strip club
yeah I used to work at a strip club when
I went to school in Las Vegas I I you
know you graduated right yeah you're
running rebel III you know so where's I
seen on red remember bright silver and
red yeah yeah silver and red we I don't
remember ever doing the ounce of
homework I don't remember ever doing
homework ever I just remember having the
best time in my life you were there
right right when though I got the last
year Tarkanian last year so like what
the in high school you know I had like
two girlfriends mm-hmm I got maybe a
[ __ ] that was a nice prize both you
know no I'm not because
we know that God was so shy or no comedy
isn't funny the high school girls it's
like being funny isn't sexy it's not
till you go to you know I had a friend
of mine come up to me you know she's
like if I didn't know you I thought you
were you were [ __ ] that's what she
told me I'm like God but then you go to
college and it's just like a whole
different ball game and it was just like
I'm like Szechwan and I don't ever
remember ever doing her I just remember
having the best time ever so I go to
school and I always wanted to be a comic
from the moment I remember being in the
universe that moment where you can
become self-aware you're like [ __ ] I'm
something I'm here I wanted to be a
comedian always I was the first one I
got I got a [ __ ] I got class clown in
sixth grade I got class clown as my
senior year I'm the only one who went to
comment and trophies that's what I got
there's a paper trail of your ass so I
graduate I I mean I got a degree in
psychology only because I knew I wanted
to be a comic and I just I love the
movie Silence of the Lambs and Basic
Instinct so I'm like [ __ ] it I'll get a
degree in psychology right right and I
took class with like the greatest sex
therapists in the country this guy named
dr. Logan who would just tell us weird
[ __ ] and I got through with a c-plus
b-minus average high gradually so I
graduated I was doing stand-up and I
would I would get my I had my own show
in three different casinos my own
stand-up show on on the strip and you
know I was opening for people at the
Riviera and I just graduated college so
I'm like you know heavily crazy long
hair then yeah I was like the Jewish
Chris Cornell I was like even though I'm
Armenia that I have this big nose at the
salon curly hair and like it wasn't for
every girl but every woman who liked it
loved it for nobody in high school
nobody wasn't for the girls but the
ladies loved it you know so I decided to
give my and say as a little gift of
myself I'm going to go and work at the
strip bar so I go around see who's
hiring everybody's mom little darlings
hires me Dasia of the showgirls excuse
me
DejaVu showgirls it's like you won't
work out like [ __ ] yeah I go I just need
these days off to do stand-up to like we
can do that so you coming your work so I
would they have me doing everything I
was bartending I was uh I was deejaying
and I was working the door and there was
this guy named T who worked there and he
was the biggest black man to this day
I've ever seen in my life his nickname
was deep space is so big and black I'd
never seen human beings this big and he
was a really nice guy and we were
working there and I remember on and
there was this guy named Malik too he
was also a door guy and we would we
would take turns bouncing which is so
funny cuz I I can't fight anybody you
know but they had me bounce I was just a
body like I remember this group of
cholos came in I'm like whee I'm
bouncing I'm like hey man we need see
IDs [ __ ] you white boy I'm like what
you'll [ __ ] you white boy [ __ ] you I'm
like dude I'm just doing my job
yeah [ __ ] you white boy I'm like listen
dude we don't want to put up with this
he's like I'll [ __ ] kick your ass
white boy I know you might be able to
get through me but this dude is gonna
[ __ ] you up and say next to me was T and
he looks over at T for a second looks
back at me he's like [ __ ] you white boy
so one day I'm there and it's a Sunday
night and nobody's getting dances
nobody's gettin dance it's like 40 guys
in the club and they're all piece of
shits and nobody's getting a dance and
that the girls are just complaining some
of the best you know it's so funny about
strip bar everybody hates strip bars but
let me tell you something nobody's there
backstabbing each other
nobody's like oh dude I gotta become the
top stripper right everybody's just
there to make a dollar there's no like
corporate weirdness so I'm hanging out
there nobody's [ __ ] getting dances so
I'm like you know what hey you know
what's really funny they actually hired
me before I tell this I
actually got hired you remember when
they said that Jay Leno used to work
strip bars and he would like MC like
shouts just for stage time oh really
yeah but he said that like no one would
listen I was doing stand-up and people
would stop listening to the girls and
talking to girls and I would just start
ripping this room I was like killing in
with your buddies away man look at this
wheelchair it's a famous bit I'm like
I'm too old man if I go down I don't
come back up man so nobody's getting
dances nope
so nobody's getting dancers I'm like you
know what man me and Malik
I got Malik let's go up there and strip
he goes why he goes let's mean you go on
[ __ ] stage how many people there was
40 dudes in there now my strippers
there's probably about 15 to 20 I'm I go
up to DJ I go me Malik or the these guys
suck let me and Malik go up on stage and
introduce it's a special dance so we're
gonna go up there and where he went up
as maverick I went up as chocolate
thunder and so I go up on stage dude and
they're like okay we got very special
dance for you guys we got some very
special strippers please walk the stage
maverick and chocolate thunder and we
come out and me and him are just [ __ ]
dancing all the strippers are [ __ ]
going whoo their pain they're throwing
money ass but their [ __ ] quarters and
quarters [ __ ] and all the guys dude
I'm doing all the [ __ ] moves that
girl like what girls do and guys go
crazy for like they'll take your shirt
off and rub it on there and so guys like
fight each other over these crotch
shirts I'm like that's disgust so I'm
taking my shirt off I'm running around
I'm throwing you know guys they're
trying to duck it I'm [ __ ] lying on
the [ __ ] pole
what are they doing malicious dude his
old man black dance I don't know if you
ever watch it old man danced at a
[ __ ] prom or some [ __ ] like that
where they just do the like never seen
an old man get away stuff yeah it's this
way stop and they're like little so he's
just doing that I'm doing pole dance
their own quarters at us dude quarter
quarters we ended up making $60 each 60
bucks in quarters to Huck
every guy as soon as we're done dancing
grab the girl I got a [ __ ] lap dance
boom that's awesome yeah did they tip
you out of course they did dude they
took care of me and I got all the
strippers love me it was how long did
you work there you know what I've always
wanted to do I worked it for about a
year I always wanted to be like
financial consulted to the strippers
because they make so much money and they
just blow it they do if you could be
like let me invest your money you could
invest a ton of cash make money and you
want to work for a while because they
are making like the order like a $10
sandwich and leave $30 tip they have no
clue of money they don't own cars
because their boyfriends spend all their
[ __ ] money if you had somebody
investing that cash like a [ __ ]
financial concern to the strippers I
think it's a great call I used a new one
that used to have a Beemer and a brand
new like expedition and ten grand in
cash yeah in her closet yeah and I was
like what are you doing I know what I'd
be doing robbing that [ __ ] happy
[ __ ] throwing on ski mask and a gun
well dancing runs in your blood man you
said used to be all your checks off list
sure I used to be part of one of the
greatest breakdancing groups in upstate
New York called the HDI breakers because
we were hosted by the Holiday Inn
we were we were sponsored by the Holiday
Inn and they would give us [ __ ] sewer
yes there's a Holiday Inn down the
street and they would sponsor us and
they gave us track suits
Tango's and we were [ __ ] I was dude when
was breakdancing come out I was like I
was like 16 I was in like I had to be
like him fourth or fifth grade oh I'm in
the group for Jim Radford Ben Rochefort
and brothers the rash four brothers they
took it solo or duo afterwards it was
great because I would hang out with them
and we go like akin and I throw a
Oh Jim my specialty was top rockin in
Papua are you pop locks
I was a top lock in pop locker because I
couldn't do the windmill I couldn't do
it I kept trying everyone would work
with me my I just could not win it will
work it was it was like my Moby Dick I'd
you that's been cuz I could do backspin
head spins I could do everything I just
couldn't do a backspin I mean the
windmill the windmill right the windmill
I couldn't do the windmill that was it
and I never felt like complete but we
all had our own thing and my thing was
top rock and I could do the problem was
my nickname was windmill wacky fruit
bubblegum that was yeah yeah so I would
breakdance and we were the headliners of
the very famous Maple Leaf Festival in
Utica yeah and we were in the newspapers
we were everything and we get signed in
[ __ ] I thought I was gonna happen I used
to break dance with a [ __ ] mullet
homeboy do you know how hard that is the
break dance with a mullet that's like
[ __ ] historical what color was the
outfit was it why do I know room in my
mind I had white with green paint
pinstripe I had a letter I had red with
red wine red wine red wine [ __ ] that
was it the judge suit we read well every
type of gold letters go up stroke
hold of it because the short that
remember that short I did with you it
was like getting taken over you had to
breakdance I found it didn't you see it
no I yeah because you're in a [ __ ]
tracksuit breakdancing yeah with Ernst
yeah me earn Jason Tebow Brody Stevens
you our skank ol Spang what's-his-name
that died the fat guy no not Freddie
Ramsey more a ramsey yeah yeah yeah did
you ever play a comics memorial no those
are I wanted to do a living memorial one
time I've seen about I'm gonna shoot my
special and I'm thinking about doing a
living memorial and have my friends go
up there and just like what they would
say if I wasn't there you just have them
light me up you know comic memorials are
the best because nobody pulls punches
yeah and I felt so bad because comics
were always like man we gotta fill this
room yeah so The Improv does Ramsey
Moore's memorial and they're like
there's not a lot of people are I'm like
dude it's a guy's [ __ ] memorial I got
worried about doing Facebook ads right
[ __ ] filling the fill in the [ __ ]
room that ends up filling his sister
comes and we're all doing jokes and
everybody's having a good time big Jay
oakerson was there me and a couple other
people and I was just student jokes
about the biggest thing I regret about
losing Ramsey Moore's I never got to do
coke off his tits like how great would
that be and in fact some of the best
comics sets I've ever seen where it
can't we're at comedians memorials like
Freddy sorro's memorial was the most
amazing thing I've ever seen
Brian Holtzman goes up and just lights
the room up [ __ ] meeting great people
got your business cards trying to
[ __ ] meet the industry so afterwards
I'm like I see this one guy I'm not
gonna say his name and I'm like dude how
funny was Holtzman talking about guys
who heard that don't even know Freddy
and they're just trying to mingle he's
like well you know and I never really
met Freddy but I was huh I just you know
I heard he was a good guy I'm like so
you're here just
Mingo he goes well yeah and I'm like oh
my god dude so [ __ ] fun yeah
memorials for comics are the [ __ ]
funniest I Ramsay was big he was very
very big now he was like he's like but
forever like obese from their very large
just I won't I don't want to say a
number cuz I don't know but it was five
bills it could have been it could have
been and that says his tits guy but
[ __ ] D was so sweet he was so nice
nice and one time he worked out at the
gym where I would go up in North
Hollywood right
and then I slump I slacked off and I
hadn't been and one day I walked in he
was in the front bike right at the
window and I walked in he was probably
like haven't seen you in a while right I
mean and I said this fat guy jokes
roughly May was hanging out with Gabriel
Iglesias and Ralphie's maze-like
yeah play I'm a vegetarian now and
everything Gabriel's like what are you
eating concrete well this episode didn't
how about that saying outdrove it this
segue to our outro dude this has been a
lot of [ __ ] fun for real thank you
got to come back oh I feel like I have
to just make stories I got to like go
out and live life just to come so I can
come over and they're doing just [ __ ]
Rock guys check out my podcast tinfoil
half you like conspiracies it's been
blown up so check it out thank you thank
you I'll check it out for sure
always a pleasure triply I love you too
guys love you too awesome comic-con Jay
Larson comedy on Facebook Twitter
Instagram and Pinterest social mean Ryan
Sickler i com Ryan Sickler at all social
media we'll talk to you all next Tuesday